welcome back to cBS them this morning
the last debate before Iowa's first in
the nation caucuses is set for tonight
in Des Moines former Vice President Joe
Biden the senator Bernie Sanders former
mayor Pete Budaj edge senators Elizabeth
Warren and Amy Klobuchar and billionaire
Tom Steyer made the cut it's the
smallest field yet in a democratic
debate the race in Iowa remains tight
for the top contenders with Biden taking
the lead in the newest poll former New
York Mayor Mike Bloomberg had the poll
numbers to qualify for tonight's debate
but he will not be on stage because he
does not have enough contributors the
multi billionaire is spending his own
money on his campaign none of the
candidates on the stage tonight will be
people of color there are now 12 people
running for the Democratic nomination
after senator Cory Booker announced he
is suspending his campaign he did that
yesterday and Cory Booker joins us at
the table to discuss I should be full
disclosure here we've been friends for a
very long very long time so I can't
pretend like I don't know it also means
you cannot use any of the information
that but I think a lot of your
supporters Cory thought you would at
least hold out and wait till Iowa what
was it that you saw that you felt that
you realize that now is a time well it
was a two-by-four we won as the
impeachment trials are gonna take me off
the stage we are running a grassroots
campaign we were gaining ground and
remember we ended the campaign with some
of the most endorsements in Iowa high
favorability in Iowa but not being on
the ground to run our race and then this
one was you just saw the debate stages
it's kind of a frustrating reality that
we're polling ahead of some of the
people in Iowa but the way that was
designed really worked against our
campaign how hard the decision was it
for you gut wrenching really we have
around this country you know people who
upended their lives dedicated themselves
invested their resources you know we ran
for a very unique mission and which was
to try to heal this country try to show
that the most important urgency to solve
big problems is to put more indivisible
back into this one nation and we're
saying love and hope and purpose we're
so polarized maybe people don't want
love and hope and you don't think about
that I would meet people one of my first
I
moments was a guy I'm running to the
debate stage guy stops and he goes dude
I want you to punch Donald Trump in the
face and I joke with him I go dude
that's a felony and let me explain to
you why the way we've beaten demagogues
and bigots and fear mongers in the past
is not by being like them the the
artists of activism in Birmingham didn't
bring bigger dogs and bigger fire hoses
they beat it by inspiring us to be the
best of who we are not the worst I can't
surrender that seduction of of being
more Trump e2b Trump for Democrats to
win back the White House for your party
to win they're gonna have to put back
the Obama coalition put it back together
they're about 110 million voters who
went to Trump we didn't vote at all yes
2012 to 2016 who in the field do you
think has the ability to gather that
group back together so the one thing I
want to challenge on that is we saw it
when we analyzed the numbers was it
wasn't the people that shifted over if
let's just take african-americans this
is why it's so important to be able to
connect authentically with the lived
experiences of African Americans because
the black vote had just stayed the same
to turnout I'd say the same under
Hillary Clinton that it was four years
earlier under Barack Obama she would be
president right now so it wasn't even
the people that moved over it was the
people that didn't participate yeah and
so what would I I want to see whoever is
the nominee and I friends with very good
friends with most of the people running
it is very important that that we can
inspire engage and ignite that whole
cold I'm sure everyone would agree but
who can do that would you consider
endorsing anybody before the convention
I would definitely will consider it 100
percent right now I am gonna take a
breather I'm gonna focus on the
impeachment trials and I have a
reelection campaign I've got to get
started on securing another six years in
the south oh yeah there's that the real
issue Senate race but what do you make
of the the controversy now between
Bernie Sanders and Elizabeth Warren at
this particular time when we're trying
to be more United if anybody wants the I
know these folks yeah nobody should be
attacking their character they are
deeply good people I see them in rooms
where nobody else sees them
let's keep it to the issues I'm gonna
just be one of those folks as I was when
I was on the debate stage saying let
let's not in any way to mean Joe from
Joe Biden all the way to Amy Klobuchar
these are really good human
beings we can't put ourselves in a
position where we eventually have one
nominee people feel some kind of way
that they don't want to support that
nominee would you consider a candidacy
as a vice president for the vice
presidency and and have you had any
conversations that I have had no
conversations I was so pleased that I
got to go through the experience and be
vetted to be one of Hillary Clinton's
final choices it was one of the more
thorough examinations of my life I've
ever been through it was nice to make it
to the would you would you consider I'm
not taking anything off the table but my
focus really is New Jersey and my state
and being with my senior senator Bob
Menendez the best dynamic duo America
has in the Senate so the debates coming
up tonight some people are more
interested than usual because of this
little rift between Warren and Sanders
take us as somebody who's been behind
the scenes take us back there and talk
about what kind of pacs are created
between these but these are the debates
matter yeah how much do they
so they matter to my campaign because
every time we were on the debate stage
we came out with really good sort of
reviews and my fundraising went through
the roof yeah
that's why I missing two of them was a
severe blow to our campaign behind the
stage I wanted scenes I want you to know
there is laughing there's camaraderie
there is goodness and decency I wish
that came out more on the debate stage
because we are a team and many of us
have been working together in the
so-called resistance stopping them from
taking away health care stopping them
from doing everything from Muslim bands
to bad judges are you concerned this
debate stage now is always I'm very
concerned I still remember the reaction
when Camille Harris dropped off the
stage amongst black women in my life
that was almost like wait a minute wait
a minute here's a woman that won in
California twice who has been
extraordinary and she couldn't even get
to Iowa how could we have a situation
that that is creating that kind of
dynamic we have got to find a way as a
party as a nation both parties to
understand that we are a diverse nation
I got to the United States Senate was
stunned when I first got there about how
little diversity there was instead of
staffs thank God Schumer worked with me
Brian Schatz to change a lot of that we
are a better nation when we bring hidden
figures together with white male
astronauts that's how we defy gravity
and go to the moon and the Democratic
Party which represents the true
rainbow coalition's of America has got
to do a better job of getting more
candidates running in all the levels
supporting a system that doesn't benefit
big money but but really big values what
are the values of our party would you
run again in 2024 oh god bless america I
am just I am eats an ice cream first
you're joking that one of the first
things it is drown my sorrows with my
two best friends Ben and Jerry III
I love the values that got me into this
presidential race I really believe this
nation has to understand that patriotism
is love of country you cannot love your
country unless you love your fellow
country minute no bitterness Cory you
work so hard for this you had so much
support um I'm curious about how you're
really feeling about money it's got to
bother you that the building barriers
are still in the race but I we all have
been moments in our career where you
know I still remembered Martha you know
so I say our unearned suffering is
redemptive I I'm not gonna be here and
bitter I had one of the best years of my
entire life running around this country
talking about the highest values of this
nation and how our civic spaces need to
reflect the values of the people we need
a revival of civic grace we need
goodness and decency and I found this in
the Senate Brene brown said it's hard to
hate up close to pull people in my
relationships with Republicans has
enabled me to do a lot of good like past
criminal justice reform we have got to
get back to these the this right now the
competish enough Russians Chinese we've
got to get back together we can do big
things as if something tells me we
haven't seen the last of senator Cory
well that's not bitter but eating ice
cream in the Miya Miya be good back up
my diet soon Rooker thank you for making
solution thank you very much
you